charlie what's up brother how are we
doing i've had a bit of a situation kind
of
fall into my lap it's not something that
you know i asked for but uh
it's here and i've got to deal with it
concerning a good friend of mine
um and i just was looking for some
advice from you about
how i approach him about the situation
and uh
how our friendship should move on from
where it is now
cool man so go on what happened
well over this uh past summer
uh i found out from my fiance who found
out from his wife
that he had been soliciting
sexually explicit pictures from uh
many other women other than his wife
some of those including uh
miners come on why yeah
man me and my fiance we went to the
police with
it a couple days after we found out
hey can i just stop you right there and
say absolutely i'm grateful for you dude
thank you to you and your fiance for
being people of character and doing hard
things good for you man
that's awesome yeah i'm i'm super
thankful for her she
she really was cut and dry with this
and was like we need to go and shoot
well you're hey you're marrying what we
make friends tough decisions hang on to
her man that's a person a character that
has
zero tolerance for freaking evil people
all right go ahead brother i'm sorry if
i'll cut you off go ahead man
you're you went to the police i know
that was hard it was uncomfortable and
then what happened
uh well since our information is
basically second hand everything we know
came from his wife right
there's nothing that's really been done
about i mean they took our statement my
report
uh and what happened but as far as i
know nothing's been done with it
okay uh when did you make this report
uh this would have been back in
june it would have been back in june
okay
so you made a report in june and here
you are
just a few weeks into the new year
what's your question for me man
so i this is like one of my best friends
i was best man at his wedding
he was supposed to walk in my wedding
and we're just
we haven't addressed it and i don't know
how i
should confront him about this
dude homie you're his best man you
confront this by going and banging on
his front
door and you have
been invited and earned the right to put
your finger in his chest and say dude
what in the world is wrong with you what
are you doing what has happened to your
brain and your spirit um this is what
best men are for
charlie it's confrontation
and it's for accountability
that's that's i mean that's why he asked
you to be his best man
right right and so you you have a
responsibility to get
active you did the right thing you
called the police
and that's the legal part of this the
friendship part of it man you are all up
in his business about that
why is that hard for you why does that
make you uncomfortable
i'm i'm not entirely sure
i just i don't want to have to
deal with that conflict that i know
that's going to be there because
hey you're not his friend then man he's
not a friend to you
you're not a friend to him call it and
then move on with your life
if you want to have relationships that
are conflict-free you're never going to
have relationships
that are worth anything i would con i
would deeply suggest
you postpone any sort of marriage plans
you have
because marriage is full of conflict the
best ones have
a lot of conflict because man that's i
mean that's that's what
good deep relationships are all about is
when the good times are good they're
good and when they are rough you ride or
die together and when somebody
violates core values of this is of any
human being man
soliciting pictures of minors um from
minors dude god almighty
um and again you are right and there's
something to think through you don't
know
it could have been his wife uh
made up stuff got angry and fired up you
did the right thing the investigation
needs to be done by the police
but man i'm telling you this if that had
been my friend
a we would have done the same thing call
the police you got to
but b man i would have been at his house
i probably would have beat the cops
there
because i take the accountability part
of my friendship real real seriously
and here's the deal vice versa whoo
man i would probably be more nervous to
face the cops in that situation and face
my buddies in that situation than the
cops because there'd be no quarter
they would probably shoot me before the
police did
and so again
has your friend not called you hadn't
reached out to you
it's just not been talked about at all
he doesn't know that i
know basically
so it's just it's hush-hush
so he's having this trouble in his
marriage is he still
married uh yes
what's his what's his wife doing about
it
man i got all kinds of questions now man
this thing's just getting weirder and
weirder
what's she doing about it yeah it's a
bit of a train wreck
so initially she was upset with them and
left them
uh obviously but so hey the guy who you
were the best men in their wedding
and he was the he's gonna be the best
man in your wedding god i hope he's
still not
he's gonna be the best man in your
wedding
he didn't call you when his wife left
him
uh he did uh and we talked
uh i hadn't known that he's had a an
addiction with
pornography before
and he had mentioned that as being part
of it
but at this point i had known but he
didn't
come out with me with the
the um deeper part of it he didn't come
out to me with that
all right charlie brother i know you
called me
to ask me what to do with your friend
and i'm turning this around on you
your friends i mean if somebody's
soliciting minors
for nude photos from them
that that's a class of person that we
don't even need to discuss any further
on this show
i think we all will be in agreement on
that and if you're listening to the show
and you're not in agreement on that like
no that's cool bro
don't ever listen to the show again just
find something else to listen to because
you're an idiot
but i think we're all in agreement on
that right
right so the problem here in this
situation charlie is you
and i'm telling you that because i love
you but if you've got a best friend on
planet earth
that you feel this uncomfortable about
calling them out on something this
big they're not your friend man
either that or you have some deep
character challenges that you're gonna
have to work through
because you owe it to yourself you owe
it to that
the kids he was getting involved with
you owe it to your future partner
you owe it to him man if someone has
entrusted you with their friendship
that's both good and bad it's hard
conversations and good conversations
and i've been recipient of some hard
hard truths in my life from men who are
close to me
and women good good friends
and it has been ugly and painful and
hard in almost
every single time it's been a gift that
i couldn't calculate how valuable that
gift was
but what you need to do is call your
friend
and say man i haven't been honest with
you i've known about this for a long
time
i called the cops on you dude and here's
the thing if it's not true if it didn't
happen
then the cops aren't going to find
anything and since
95 or whatever the crazy number is of
people in this country look at
pornography
the cops can roll their eyes if he did
they do an investigation then he's going
to get busted and he should
okay it's that simple but you owe it to
your friend
who was the best man in your wedding and
who was so close to you you were going
to have him in your wedding
you owe it to him to call him and be
upfront with him
and to confront to hold accountable and
in that process man you're with him
right
you don't we don't abandon our friends
not like that
um but we don't gloss over it and just
be like oh sweet dude cool bro
no man charlie you got to step up here
or
he's not your friend and you gotta just
walk away and let that sucker ride
but man
we've got to have friends guys
and gals we gotta have friends and that
doesn't mean just people who surround us
with
good things that make us smell like
flowers and roses
but who will tell us hard hard truths
about ourselves
who will
show up at our front door when we need
help and it will show up at our front
door
to put a size 12 boot
interface right in my right my mouth
right my teeth
and man maybe i'm just a lucky guy man
that i've got friends that will do that
for me but charlie you need to be that
guy
if anybody out there has great close
friends
and they they're like i don't want to
get have that conflict have the conflict
man that's what you're supposed to do
all right i'm just gonna go on
thanks for the call charlie hey here's
the deal have this conversation charlie
and then call me back
because i wanna know how it goes um it's
probably not gonna go well
but that's a good thing this kind of
conversation can't go well
but let me know how it goes